[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to
another episode of honest trailers
commentaries today's episode
coming to america uh i'm here joined as
always by lawn and danielle
on either my left or bottom right side
uh
and uh we're gonna watch the trailer
give you our behind-the-scenes thoughts
uh show you some deleted scenes
respond to viewer comments and questions
and then tease ya with next week's
honest trailer you all know the drill
um we're talking about a classic today a
classic comedy which is usually the
hardest
uh of films to make jokes about because
they're already funny
so if we got even a sensible chuckle out
of you this week job well done team
um cause uh this movie is fantastic and
it really holds up on rewatch
that at least is my opinion what do you
guys say what do you think about coming
to america oh heart agree um this is
i've said before i have two lists
of favorite movies list the list of
there i know they're bad but i love them
and then the list of movies that are
just good
this is like top five my just good list
it has been since i was a kid
um i probably saw this way too early
um before i understood anything because
i definitely had this movie memorized at
like
seven so what's a royal penis
exactly yeah i was definitely young
enough when i saw that to where that
scene still felt like ooh
like i'm i'm not supposed to be seeing
this
like i definitely was still like i don't
know if i said i was probably 10
or 11 when i saw this but uh in fact i
only think it came out when i was 10 or
11. but um
yeah it was still too early for me to be
fully appreciating the world of zamunda
yeah it's just it's funny to think back
on on movies and
it's classical i was just going to say
moments like that where i i would watch
um ace ventura at 10 years old and like
he'd be
hanging from the fan like spinning
around with a woman off screen and i'd
be like
why is she spinning him around on that
fan that looks fun yeah i had talked to
my uh
dad to taking me to see ace ventura and
i remember
him like looking at me at that scene
like does he know
you know what's going on is he following
this
like yeah chemo but now we know and uh
yeah
like it's like danielle said and like
this is a great comedy
uh and it's all it's all resting on the
shoulders of eddie murphy and to a
slightly lesser extent but still amazing
uh arsenio hall
um they're just like i was gonna say
usually with our comedies it's hard to
do the honest trailer because they're
there's like a there's a meta level
they're already not taking themselves
seriously
but this movie i didn't it's just a good
story like it is very funny
but it's not just like throw the kitchen
sink at you anything for a laugh we're
not taking this world
seriously it really invests in the
characters of the story
it's the real story it's a it's a nice
romantic sort of fairy tale almost
um and i think that's what makes it hold
up so well
is that it's really just a good movie
telling a good story that also is very
fun
yeah yeah it seems like a perfect fit
for eddie murphy to like the movie star
not the comedian
um because he gets to do things he he
didn't normally do and it seems like it
just seems like a very natural fit
unlike i'm sorry something like you know
the golden child where it's like
oh we gotta edit this movie up because
we have eddie murphy in it now like he's
it seems to be child slander
i'm sorry i'm sorry it's a little
there's some
it's on the second list danielle yeah it
doesn't totally hold up
i forgot that charles dance was the
villain in that until revisiting it not
long ago do you know that
do you remember that tywin lannister's
the bad guy lancer yeah that
and uh and last action hero um long man
that i remember but anyways yeah i don't
know how much more there is to say
except this is a great comedy and eddie
murphy's fantastic in it like
overall thoughts that's that's pretty
much where i stand
yeah how do you feel about the sequel
coming up excited uh uh worried
uh i always have the first one and
that's how i feel about the sequel i
don't know i mean obviously we've only
seen like little bits of it um
i don't even i don't know who wrote it
or who directed i need to look that up
um because that might change my opinion
but yeah like i i will always have this
first one
uh this rewatch was so good to me that
i'm like trying to find the script
because i actually want to go through
and like read the script and that
rarely happens um i don't know that i'm
going to be wanting to go through and
read the script for coming to america
too but we'll see either way everyone's
going to be talking about it for like a
weekend it's going to be really exciting
i uh normally this is the sort of thing
i would be really
nervous about because it's always touch
and go to revisit comedies this many
years later there's just kind of an
inherently
sort of like you can't recapture the
vibe from so many decades ago
but uh this one was directed by craig
brewer who just worked with eddie murphy
and wesley snipes who's also in it
on dolomite is my name which was so good
um
and i think kenya barris worked on this
script like the blackish
creator there's one of three people
who's credit on the script so i think
there's a there's a better chance than
average i think it's got an above
average shot
at being fun um over
a lot i mean i honestly though i thought
it was fun last year so who knows maybe
maybe these revivals are coming around
yeah i'm expecting some medium fun the
trailer looked the trailer looked pretty
good i got some chuckles out of it
um and there is a there was a ryan
coogler pitched michael b
jordan sequel to this that that eddie
passed on he he wanted to do it like all
the same people
everybody get back in the get back in
the van we're doing it again um and i'll
also uh
give a shout out to my own pitch on
movie fights that was um coming from
america where we were going to send
jaden smith to zamunda
to war torns and i still think that
would be good that's a good concept uh
with that said
all of that's kind of what makes me feel
like normally i would be really hesitant
because also the like oh he's got to
come back to
queens and meet the long-lost son it's
like the most obvious
take on a coming to america sequel um so
yeah
i don't know i'm i'm sort of of two
minds about it we'll see we'll see what
happens
we shall see now let's see the honest
trailer for coming to america
the first one
theme song surprisingly not by eddie
murphy was it dale rogers
how you gonna talk yeah
that will probably suck ass revisit the
modern fairy tale that
asks what if one of those nigerian
prince scams were real
damn i knew i should answer that email
according to america
get ready for a series of late 80s snl
sketches held together by the nuclear
charisma of eddie murphy
when you think of garbage think of akin
that has him cast against type as a
naive romantic
then makes up for it by casting himself
as everyone else too
in a formula that works one hundred
percent of the time fifty percent of the
time
in hell before one shot poisoned out of
another man's ass
meet a key us yeah you know you
struggling when you
put an actual rim shot into the into the
movie yeah yeah i've never seen norbit
um
oh wow that's not normal i
will not oh
that clip that we picked from norbit
does a very good job of summing up the
experience of watching the entire
film door but it's just it's just him
playing like in coming to america
he's playing characters that are rude
there's some stereotype
humor but they also feel like organic
characters that he created
and arsenio and in orbit it feels like
just what's a good stereotype
do that one that way it just doesn't
feel like there's no second level to it
got it all right so i'll pass an orbit
i'll take your word for it
but bowfinger which we bring up there
brilliant another
fantastic movie where he plays multiple
roles and invests
like two very different very fleshed-out
three-dimensional characters mindhead
um all right let's keep going yet
another royal immigrant
who comes to the us to take our jobs
seriously it's an epidemic
but he's surprisingly humble for a guy
whose face is on money
and surprisingly righteous for a guy
with his own dick washer
the royal penis is clean your highness
making him one of the only spoiled rich
kids to turn out pretty cool
i think the director can manage that so
congratulations to whichever
kind-hearted nanny raised the king
because it was definitely not his
parents
journey to a wakanda known as a munda
a fictional african kingdom thought up
by white guys
rich beyond all comprehension with a
bachelor prince who's shy around girls
and the king dresses like a big cat but
a king will gladly leave the fame and
fortune behind foreign
just a moment of uh of synergy i believe
they said that
um coming to america too
is going to have the same costume
designer as black panther
so yeah carter there's some crossover
yeah um and they look pretty damn cool
so
that's exciting and like i this was
going to be a movie that was going to
come out in theaters the sequel
this is not like straight to streaming
let's give you a couple bucks and see
what you could do um this is like
this is a movie um so i'm pretty excited
to see a big budget version of coming to
america not that'll make it any more
funny
but uh at least it'll be pretty to look
at
anywho keep going yeah i mean i'm
looking forward to especially
zamunda like we'll get to see a more
lavishly budgeted like
what what what is creating zamunda now
that it's taking on iconic proportions
in all of our minds
yeah they tripled the elephant budget
chance
there was already steel this porsche
girlfriend
yeah i know he's a jerk but i guess bro
code into the border huh
along for the ride to the big apple is
semi his
ballet personal trainer human toy
if his job is to be the royal best
friend he's terrible at it
i feel like a complete idiot i doubt we
will ever find your queen what's not
fair is me doing manual labor
do you realize i have not had sex since
we got to america things are going so
well with lisa
i do not care but every king needs his
queen
and lisa is a hard-working independent
woman with principles did arsenio
uh did arsenio act
aft before or after this outside of his
own talk show
oh gosh i don't know i'd have to put up
uh there's gonna be some phantoms
arsenio fans somewhere that will be able
to answer this yeah
right i'm tempted to say he was in
like i don't think this is his only
acting role ever
but i don't i think this is like his his
biggest role like i don't i don't think
he was like leading a lot of other movie
casts
but you watch this and you're like he's
super good i wonder if this was like a
fluke or if he was just like i'd rather
be a talk show host i mean
both fair oh he's also in
um uh harlem nights that's right
that was their follow-up to this having
eddie murphy um yeah i'm looking i'm
looking at it now you know he's he
no it's small parts and stuff some tv
uh yeah i think he got he got into this
you know amazing gig as like a talk show
host and his show was
a mainstay of tv for so long like those
are the years he probably wouldn't have
been doing other movies
yeah this was his um god what was that i
forgot the name of it
jay leno and pat marita buddy cop movie
oh oh god what's that called
um i'll look it up that that's a
showdown question that i would get
killed
on not remember it's like moving
violation collision courts
i'm so glad we'll need to do a group
watch of collision course
where it's like a 1989 action comedy
collision course
yeah oh it's the cursor to russian
hudson's also in that
yeah i have to say buddy cop that was
when like every comedian got a buddy cop
movie if they wanted they would just be
like who would be a weird person to
match you up with
all right you go and leno's like yeah
i'm gonna i'm gonna go back to my show
i don't like this i had to change out of
my genes yeah didn't like it right
tim robbins you want to do what uh
martin lawrence go for it
nothing nothing to lose
okay let's keep going uh and we'll watch
collision course later
and lisa is a hard-working independent
woman with principles
that she'll quickly sell out for a
bigger house like the rest of the
boomers
if you like we can give it all up now
and experience james earl jones as you
love to see him most
being someone's dad you may not be my
father sir
but you will always be my daddy witness
a truly impressive parade of
soon-to-be-famous actors
from samuel l jackson getting a start as
this bad mother effort
anybody move out blow your head off to
cuba gooding jr as
boy getting haircut to a young paula
abdul choreographing the dance scenes
even the royal penis lady got work
if eddie and arsenio lon you put out
like
everyone in this movie went on to bigger
well not necessarily bigger because it's
an enormous movie but everybody in this
movie was cast and cast again right
like i feel like literally every scene
if you do a good job of scanning there's
somebody who went on to like
a noteworthy career in film or tv like
little parts i mean like we were
pointing out like frankie faison who's
the landlord like
he's in all the hannibal lecter movies
and he was just in luke cage
like uh yeah but just like like to a
weird and obviously eric lasalle
is daryl in this and then he went on to
be on er and logan and
there's just dozens of examples of that
where like
a person has one line in this and then
but like 10 years later
had like a huge career it's it's weird
yeah
and they just just played himself in
uncut gems in 2019
nice they just had a uh uh an article
i guess it was uh arsenio and eddie just
went on
fallon or something and they uh and they
said like the studio made us
cast a white guy like you have to pick
one white person to be in this movie
and they're like and they gave him like
three white guys and they're like louie
anderson he's pretty funny
how did louis anderson get on that list
of like the three acceptable whites
i don't know because i'm sure you know
the part is like guy who could
conceivably work at a
fast food fast food yeah it's like you
get three
here's three white stand ups and they're
like yeah that's hilarious louie's funny
um so yeah that was that was the
agreement between them and the students
yeah
gilbert godfrey was this close and yeah
that's right
he wouldn't name the other ones maybe
sam kennison who knows
um that would have been amazing now i'm
sorry
go to where the phone is yeah all right
you want a burger look at my face
keep playing fewer parts we could have
had don cheal in our lives a whole
decade sooner
so sit back and enjoy eddie murphy's 80s
comedy about africans
that's aged better than his other 80s
i have to go off to the woods of africa
and find me some crazy naked zebra
that takes you back to a golden era when
these two were on top of the world
before they stopped working all the time
and went off to enjoy their families and
spend their millions
wait celebrities are allowed to do that
will somebody please tell bruce willis
we didn't know whether to burn it or put
in a museum
i'm sure they said the same thing about
me welcome to the party pal
it ended many years ago you can rest now
first of all i cannot believe cosmic sin
is a real film
that is released in year of our lord
2021 and we'll have to do a double
feature with that
and and the leno film you may be
wondering lon is that the exact same
middle eastern production company that
makes all of bruce willis's
direct-to-streaming releases
yes it is what's going on what's going
on there
company there's one company out of egypt
that produces
all of these bruce willis movies because
they're all like they're all just
generic action movies and then bruce
willis shows up for three days to do a
supporting role they're all really like
kellen lutz or josh duomel or in this
case i believe that was
frank gorilla uh movies and then bruce
shows up to do like three days but it's
all one company they just constantly
do this and they just you know bruce
just shows up
he probably doesn't even know what the
titles are what the movies are about
he literally just shows up well that's
fascinating but i guess also the
the thing that i was fascinated by and
just reading i guess it was an older
interview with eddie
murphy because he's back doing adult
comedy but he was very frank with the
sense that like i've made enough money
i've been funny i've been on top of the
world and had all the
fame and fortune like i never need to
work again i'm just gonna like maybe
make some family movies here and there
and like
i don't need to i don't need to do
stand-up again i don't need to uh
be the biggest movie star in the world
again and i was like that is a very rare
and refreshing point of view from a
celebrity like we didn't have to watch
him
completely wear out his welcome although
i know he made some stinking
some stinky movies uh uh near the tail
end there but he spent like a good
10 15 years just doing his thing like
and and not doing comebacks um until now
so
we'll see how that goes and then the
thing to say is it does make it exciting
when
when he does like if eddie murphy this
whole time had been filling
cinemas with just like generic whatever
warmed over
eddie murphy comedies we wouldn't really
be as excited for him to be
back now and doing stuff like the
dolomite movie or like this but it is
exciting because he hasn't been around
as much
yeah yeah and it's like we'll never
think of like de niro pacino bruce
willis from like the output of the last
20 years but
but because if we did it'd be real sad
it just sucks i mean imagine if it's
nothing out of pacino for a decade
and then duncancino like just imagined
imagine the cultural impact that would
have had how much excitement there is
it dunk that what's that sound
duncancino uh
it's dunk it's dunk it's not al anymore
it's dunk
but yeah we're so hyped for the the
return of like rick moranis to like say
a couple lines in a ghostbusters movie
or something like that like that could
be
that could be all of them but um but no
they had to make uh grudge match
one two and three oh well uh all right
let's wrap this up
starring the nutty successor
burger queen and twins
the founder city slicker 2
legend of curly's glow and twins
robert mugabe and sir this is a wendy's
the prince's bride
since this takes place in a shared
universe does that mean that eddie has
an identical millionaire twin named
valentine
yeah weird move on uh john lannister's
part to uh be that
it's just like a little moment like a
little beat of like oh those two
homeless guys are the rich guys from
trading places ha ha
fine great okay to linger on it the way
he does is so
self-indulgent it's like come on john
don't don't get high on your own supply
yeah yeah i hear there's an american
werewolf in zamunda
let's go over there anyways uh that's
the trailer thank you guys for watching
um please subscribe to the channel that
you are currently on and like the video
that you're currently watching and give
it a little
ring of the bell so you never miss a
thing because you don't want to miss a
thing like that aerosmith song
um we now bring to you uh i believe we
had some outtakes some deleted scenes
some cut jokes
let's roll them but akeem will gladly
leave all the fame and fortune behind
for a chance to ditch his african
fiancee for a light-skinned girl with an
office job
starring the king of queens burger king
my wife john landis's prince of dorkness
the martial artist secretly known as
prince getting a semi
paul and royal oats all the king's men
the princess inquiries meal order bride
bride of plucky famous amos
richie glow worm lionel richish
prince of perms yeah the scion king
move father to blocker a royal pain in
the ass
i am your father the queen's gambit
american booty arranged marriage
story sleepless in zamunda
how are there two sets of twins in this
one club you know i'm starting to think
this was a fetish night
every one of those gold uh i can't
believe it goes sleepless
in seattle
queen's gambit he is embarking on a
gambit
including good point yeah come on guys
the the borough
yes of course pre-aquaman many kids
queens boulevard
about mcdowell oh yeah
oh yeah uh all right we got a couple
questions
a couple questions to cover uh uh keep
them coming in in the chat uh ryan pop
minimum script if you have a chance
johanna stromer writes uh if you could
greenlight a movie where the main actor
plays multiple roles what actor would
you choose
who do you think could do like an eddie
murphy style play every part
oh i don't think he could do it but i
think it'd be funny if it was hugh
jackman
you jack would certainly love to try yes
he would yo you
know what would be fun is to see
christian bale because christian bale
likes to like
disappear into the role it'd be funny to
see him try to do that but like three
different guys in the same movie so he's
got to like
drastically lose weight halfway through
the shoot to play one
and i'd like i'd like to see him him
work that out
i like him to just do the clumps just
christian bell to just do that
right but you've got to take like each
one you've got to shoot a year apart
because he's just not he's not going to
wear a fat suit he's going to put on
50 pounds yeah yes it's like boyhood we
have to plant it over the
course of a second i mean he's going to
do it and if you're going to believe
that there's five different christian
bales at that table
yeah well i'm going with uh the usual
america's hottest actor
paul giamatti i think he could probably
do uh
you can never have too many gmattes so i
i also think he
actually does have a lot of range and
you could just do like historical
fiction gmati like uh gangster giamatti
and
you know i want to collect them all like
pokemon uh yeah planet of the apes
chimp giamatti like i can see him
nailing this entire range
yeah uh all right so um
panthera i'm gonna have you guys gonna
have to go back in time for this one
of the characters in the movie played by
eddie which surprised you the most to
find out it was
daddy all along
i guess the white dude yeah for me yeah
there's an old jewish guy
in the in the barber shop is a that's a
leap because the just the makeup's
really good even
without him doing the voice he's like
that doesn't look like anybody
like the sexual chocolate singer i think
we can all tell
uh yeah agreed it was it was definitely
that guy in the barbershop
um yeah so there you go you guys are far
right
far right um if you have any more
questions too bad uh ryan didn't pick
him up fast enough
and if you don't that's fine sometimes
you just uh everything's
self-explanatory
so come back next week where i'm sure
you'll have many more questions
and we will have all of the answers for
you because we are going to
cast a spell over your uh over you next
week
um and you'll have to come back for that
uh next week on honest trailers
commentaries thanks for watching
[Music]
bye
you